Філософія нашої команди –
це допомогти тваринам,
які зазнають шкоди,
власне, через людей.
Через те, що вони створили,
і через те, чим не вміють
користуватися тварини.
Зазвичай потрібно повзти,
наприклад, по вузькій трубі,
де в кінці знаходиться
постраждала тварина,
або повзти по вузькій трубі,
у кінці якої сидить зла собака.
Тобто ти повзеш по трубі,
а тобі назустріч повзе зла собака.
Команда порятунку тварин —
це громадська організація.
У нас всі, хто працюють, — це люди
зі схильністю до авантюризму і ризику,
тому що чи буде в нас якась оплата
за роботу, чи не буде — це просто лотерея.
Ми виїжджаємо на виклик в будь-якому разі,
чи є оплата, чи немає оплати.
Спочатку, коли викликів було мало,
про нас знало мало людей,
виходило так, що тільки
один екіпаж їздив по місту,
і цього вистачало.
Потім, коли викликів ставало
все більше й більше,
то це вже було неможливо,
і потрібна була участь
більшої кількості людей.
Зараз у нас п'ятнадцять рятувальників,
окремо чотири диспетчери,
п'ять автомобілів,
цілодобово щонайменш
одна машина працює.
У нас все, що є, — це автівки,
які мають комплект приблизно
однакового спорядження задля того,
щоб дістати тварину з будь-якого місця.
Цю машину нам кілька років тому
подарували благодійники,
і це була перша машина,
на якій я, власне, як водій
їздила рятувати тварин.
Там кіт у вентиляції
п'ятиповерхового будинку.
Спочатку команда порятунку займалася
майже тільки котами на деревах,
тобто виклики поступали
на мій телефон,
який я раніше вказав у статті,
а потім вже цей телефон став
диспетчерським телефоном,
і це вже став телефон команди,
а не мій особистий.
Але якось до нас звернулися люди
з проханням допомогти врятувати собаку.
Взимку собака пройшла по тонкому
льоду на острів і там залишилась.
Потім лід розтанув,
і з берега її всі чули,
ніхто не міг її дістати.
Складністю було те,
що в мене була фобія:
я дуже боявся собак,
які мене покусали в дитинстві.
Ми припливли на човнах на той острів,
виловили собаку,
відвезли назад на землю.
І після того виклику
з собакою на острові
ДСНС почало переадресовувати
виклики на нас.
І тоді вже організація
запрацювала на повну силу,
викликів стало багато.
[тривожно нявчить кіт]
Виявляється, що просто діставати тварин
з важкодоступних місць недостатньо.
Бо незрозуміло, що потім
робити з цією твариною,
яку ми, власне, витягли звідкілясь.
Доводиться забирати цих тваринок
до себе і якось їм допомагати.
Ми рятуємо всіх тварин,
що [потребують допомоги]
в Києві та області.
Це не тільки коти й собаки.
Це різні птахи, різні дикі
тварини, це кажани.
Кажани занесені
до Червоної книги України,
тому ми їх не тільки рятуємо,
а ще й вигодовуємо, лікуємо
та після цього відпускаємо на волю.
Одним з перших викликів у мене
було вигнати кажана з домівки.
Я вперше побачила досить близько
це миле створіння з милими добрими оченятками.
Цієї зими я перетримала 250 кажанів.
Для гібернації кажанам
потрібна температура +4...+8°C.
Ну, саме таку температуру можна
налаштувати в холодильнику.
І, коли весною я робила випуски,
це дуже такий приємний момент.
Мої друзі кажуть:
«Не чіпайте Таню, у неї випускний».
Це час, коли я збираю цих кажанчиків,
розвожу їх по тих адресах,
де вони були знайдені, і випускаю.
Зараз ми зробили два заміри.
Перший замір показує,
на якій глибині залягає кіт,
другий замір показує,
на якій відстані від торцевого боку будинку
знаходиться вентиляційний отвір.
За допомогою цих двох замірів
ми зможемо точно визначити місце,
в якому саме місці знаходиться кіт,
і зможемо його дістати,
пробивши там стіну.
Оскільки я з дитинства займалася
туризмом, альпінізмом,
я розуміла, як працювати з мотузками,
знала різні мотузкові техніки.
То я почала спочатку
знімати котів з дерев.
Свого першого кота я врятувала
взагалі десь у чотири роки.
Ми йшли з батьком і почули,
як на дереві кричить
кошенятко мале.
І ми його забрали
додому, відмили.
І потім зробили йому
всі щеплення необхідні
та прилаштували його
до нових господарів.
Тобто це був, мабуть,
перший порятунок.
Ну й, мабуть, з дитинства я дуже
любила всіх тварин і все живе.
Коли зараз літо й тепло,
я можу певних тварин вивозити
на дачу і тут за ними доглядати.
І зараз в мене тут перебувають
пташки, які післяопераційні.
Я дуже сподіваюся, що їх можна
буде прилаштувати в притулок.
У кожної людини в команді
є якісь спеціальні навики,
яких немає в інших людей.
Я інженер за фахом, по-перше.
По-друге, я спелеолог,
тобто у мене є навики
пролазити в різні щілини,
лазити по деревах, працювати
з мотузкою на висоті та під землею.
Необхідно вміти володіти
електроінструментом.
І не мати фобій висоти, глибини,
не мати клаустрофобії.
80% звернень на диспетчерську
лінію — це не виклики,
це звернення інформаційного характеру,
яким потрібно надати консультацію і все.
Якщо є дійсно виклик,
диспетчер задає уточнюючі запитання,
формується екіпаж
і починається робота.
Перший виклик може надійти як о шостій
годині ранку, так і о першій годині дня.
[свердлить стіну]
Чим цікава ця робота, це тим,
що щодня ти не знаєш абсолютно,
що на тебе буде чекати.
Тут ще є певний момент якоїсь новизни,
щоразу адреналіну, якогось драйву.
І це те, що захоплює,
і це те, через що виникає певна
залежність від цих порятунків,
через що хочеться цим займатися.
Задля того, щоб успішно
врятувати життя,
потрібно щоразу проробити
нову стратегію,
і від цього залежить життя тварини.
[свердлить стіну]
[крізь звуки електроінструменту
чутно нявчання кота]
[кіт нявчить]
Я роблю це тому,
що можу, мабуть.
І тому ще ми працюємо,
тому що нема більш кому.
Тобто ми єдина така організація,
і якщо ми не врятуємо тварину,
то переважно ніхто її не зможе врятувати.
– [російською] Ну що, дістали?
– [російською] Так, дістали.
[російською] А де він був?
Боже, це ж скільки днів він там кричав!
Будь-яка соціальна ініціатива,
будь-яке волонтерство відіграє
дуже корисну роль.
Кожен громадянин повинен
щось зробити для своєї Батьківщини.
Є люди, які підтримують армію.
Є люди, які підтримують дику природу,
які висаджують дерева на місця,
пошкоджені пожежами тощо.
Будь-який вклад у розвиток країни важливий.